pregnant i hate it first going okay so i
i'm gonna give you my opinion and you
can comment on it i think
it's 99.999
the woman's fault if she gets pregnant
why do you think that because we are in
control of
sex we
one there's a million forms of birth
control
two
you can you can
you get to pick who you sleep with yep
and three
there's condoms and four you can even
get an abortion
so i think if you get pregnant it's your
own fault so you said it's 99.9 women's
i think that men out here just shooting
up and random girls are dumb okay i
think you guys are stupid
so do you think so but but i would say
that the responsibility is mostly on the
woman rather than the guy
so i
i
don't disagree that culturally so
there is more power in the woman in
regards to getting pregnant
but to say that men are only responsible
for one percent of that i disagree
i would say
because it does take two tango because
here's the thing right
it is true that most men would have sex
with anything yeah
but there are the small percentage of
men who maybe have a lot of options
wouldn't
they
exercise discipline especially if their
time is money right but even even if
let's say they wear a condom right what
happened to drake
how does it count it does count that
happens to really successful men all the
time no no what i mean is like that's
not that's completely on her that's not
even one person but that's what i'm
saying like even if a guy wears a condom
a girl can take it
it's true yeah that's that's true that
like that's an exception
that's not his fault but i would i would
say if she got pregnant from that that's
that's not 99 her that's 100 percent her
yeah that's none of him yeah i'm saying
if it was
oh yeah
[ __ ] you drake
no but if um if a guy if a guy has
because if she chooses to have
unprotected sex with him yeah she's
making that choice but he's making okay
but let's say she does who is the who is
the choice to take the plan b pill
who has honor who has the power to yeah
she does she that's why who is who has
the power to get an abortion
it is her yeah it's true does a man have
any say in that i agree so that's why i
say it's it's her own fault you could
you could okay let's say let's say
one you can track your cycle there's
only like five days
in a month or whatever that you're
really likely to get pregnant i know it
can happen outside of that yeah okay but
you can track your cycle
that doesn't work what can you do a
condom okay
if that doesn't work you can get a plan
b pill
if that doesn't work next time around
get an iud so if that doesn't work no no
i'm not done okay if that doesn't work
and you get pregnant you can go get an
abortion
the men have no say in this none
i know so so like that's what i said
culturally so i don't understand how
these girls are saying oh it just
happened what do you mean it just
happened that i agree that's silly like
any girls just like oh my gosh it just
happens you got pregnant like
you you played that part yeah here's my
question to you right so there's like
over 40 forms of birth control for women
yeah
if it were reversed there was over 40
forms of birth control for men yeah but
it was still obviously women who choose
who have sex with so i'm saying the
intersexual dynamics yeah yeah yeah yeah
but in terms of culturally it is men who
has the birth control power not women
mm-hmm
would that then change your position
with that who's responsible
and who's responsible
no because at the end of the day women
men have no say in abortion if you get a
girl pregnant and you're crying to her
and saying i don't want you to get that
abortion
there ain't [ __ ] there ain't [ __ ] you
can do you can't save that kid
and
so at the end of the day a woman can't
have a child that they don't want to
have
so i fully agree with that i fully i'm
fully like that's my personal but like
if i ever got pregnant so i am sexually
active i'm not on contraception but i
tell men straight away i'm like come in
me don't come on me and i'm like but i
know if that if that happens i'm like
well it's my responsibility to be like
girl you're what what are you doing in
these streets
we're having a long host season oh my
god
the house season i am that's why i tell
std that ruins your life i've already
had chlamydia i got committee
don't do this to yourself
i'm not familiar being responsible i got
committee of being beautiful you clearly
did it like it wouldn't have been that
responsive i was 18 it was the second
guy i ever slept with my life we were
friends we were xyz and then i get that
text being like hey and i was like hey
he's like oh so um
no okay
but that but that is what i learned
people don't know he didn't he didn't
come inside me either
okay but that doesn't mean they were
being responsible
but a lot of people if you don't know
the media is passed just through contact
they don't need to come inside you so
even if they've got come in here on
their hand
okay okay
what would reduce your odds i mean at
that point at that point i was a very
different human being but i'm like oh i
had to come in but you're not because
you're doing the same thing now well no
no because i make sure that everyone i
make sure that everyone also how do you
make them get tested and make them great
really we don't say clean either so i
was an ex sexual health professional we
don't say clean we say std free because
obviously the opposite of clean is dirty
and we don't we don't um perpetuate that
like stigma so i'll say like
i literally will say to people and be
like hey i'll tell them i'm like i'm not
on contraception but i i get tested very
regularly wait wait you're not wait
you're not on birth
control no
and that is because
i can't
and that is because it [ __ ] it [ __ ]
up my hair [ __ ] up my body it [ __ ]
up everything you know what god [ __ ] up
your body a baby
but
i'm responsible for that i'm responsible
for that what income no no but what i'm
saying is abortion the wrong thing is
you know what else [ __ ] up your body
abortion person yeah yeah and your
mental health this is what we're talking
about it's responsibility is that i'm
like if that happened so
i tell men and they're like oh pull out
method or
i'm like okay like
if you do you want to use a condom like
cool like i'm like yeah i'd rather they
did but if i ever got pregnant i
wouldn't be like well it's your fault
i'd be like no this is okay but this is
like point in case where women are using
abortion as a form of birth control
instead of something that should be used
in an emergency oh no no so like
fortunately that's it i'm 27 i've like
had a lot of i've had a lot of girls
like yeah um but that's it i'm like yeah
we will either i'll tell men and so a
lot of men a lot of men that i sleep
with
actually to be fair most of them are
like well i'm either not going to come
on you or i'm going to wear a condom or
i'm like you're just not gonna finish
like okay okay we'll finish in a another
way
um
and if a guy is like i'm still gonna try
and finish beside you i'm like no you're
not because like i'll call you daddy but
i don't want to make you a daddy like
that's literally like
i will say that to men all the time
i just want to clarify some
understanding so right now you're in the
streets right yeah yeah yeah yeah you're
street you're street in you know street
even that is that is a judgment on women
to be like hey casual sex is not okay
for women
i didn't say if it was okay for me what
what i'm what i'm what i'm judging you
for i'm gonna be honest yeah yeah go for
it it's just it's just like this is so
irresponsible because if i'm
understanding it right okay
so so you're sleeping with these guys
you don't you don't know
them i know i don't know very well okay
okay you date them you date them and and
you're not on birth control you have
them finishing you no they don't finish
me no no no no no no no no no no no no
no never never not come
i was gonna correct her but i wanted to
see how far this would go oh god oh my
god no okay no no that's my bad that oh
no there's that here's the love here's
the honor if you can't come in here come
on her i tell men straight away straight
away i'm like do not finish inside me
and that's why i say
i'm like i will call you daddy do you
want to be a daddy they all go oh
you're only you don't have the more
condoms though your only form of is pull
out oh no no like they they can wear a
condom but then then it's on the guy
that they're like well i don't want to
like you you get to pick so like like do
do you make them wear condoms i don't
make them if they don't want to okay but
then i i have the conversation with them
i'm like look
you've got choices either you don't
finish you wear a condom okay or you
pull out but i'm well aware that if they
don't if they don't pull out in time i'm
like
um i get tested very regularly that's it
ex sexual health professional sexual
health is the one part of our health
that we are fully responsible for we are
fully responsible for getting tested we
are fully responsible
i do think as an individual as a woman
if i was to get pregnant from my
reckless behavior i'd be like it's not
on you it's on me i have taken that risk
yeah and i'll take that risk but because
i am very comfortable with the idea of i
know the washer's not nice yeah i'm not
here like if i get pregnant i have an
abortion yeah i'm like do you know what
if like you don't get in a car thinking
i'm gonna be in a car accident but you
know full well every time you get in a
car or you get on a plane yeah there is
a low-key chance that this could not end
well for me it's just